hey everybody welcome back to planet
coaster and welcome to a short series in
which I'll try to build a ski resort I
know this is a bit strange given that
this game is called planet coaster and
that it's July right now but please hear
me out I'm super passionate about ski
resorts and skiing and ski lifts even
and I've always wanted to do a series in
planet coaster where I built a ski
resorts and just talk about these things
while I'm building it so yeah here we go
I hope you guys will allow me to be
super nerdy about a topic that is
different than rollercoasters or theme
parks or cities this time around
although I do have to say there are some
really interesting overlaps between the
roller coaster industry and the ski lift
industry that I'll probably get into in
the rest of this video but for now just
a quick introduction as to what I'm
doing because I'm gonna try to not lose
sight of that while I'm ranting about
stuff I'm starting off with a station
for the chairlift and this will be the
first lift of the resorts I'm keeping
the resort generally quite small so
it'll be based on small Hills rather
than big mountains because really the
map is quite limited in planet coaster
but I'm going to try and go for a
somewhat realistic size I'm trying to
build a resort which really feels like
it could be a real ski resorts if not
only Alps then the somewhere in the
Black Forest in Germany or near
winterberg or something like that an
area with smaller hills but large enough
to build a ski resort out of it somehow
now I'm building a station around the
pre-made station of the chairlift and
planet coaster here because I want to
build a double Meier like chairlift and
I'm kind of need to explain a lot about
that sentence basically dopa Meier is
one of the manufacturers of skills and
probably the most well known and
prominent one you find a lot of them in
year
especially if you go skiing in austria
or switzerland or anywhere in that area
and they just have a particular look to
their ski lifts which basically allowed
me to make the assessment that the
ingame ski lifts are based on dopa my
ski lifts and I'm saying ski lifts but
you know in game they're not really
meant as ski lifts but we have a cable
car and a chairlift and I think both of
them are based on dopa Maier ones I'm
building the chairlift here which very
much looks like a two-seater
dopaminergic airlift and then when we
look at the gondola I don't think
there's a question about it it uses CWA
cabins which are Kevin's the we're gonna
have been purchased by De Palma and that
have long been used by double Meyers so
that is definitely a top of Meyer cable
car so yeah that that makes me feel like
I'm right to base this ride on top of
Maier only problem is as much as the
chairs and gondolas themselves look like
the Paul Meyers the rest of the ride
really doesn't so I'll be spending a
fair bit of this episode trying to build
a realistic looking dope on my own ski
lifts and trying to also explain to you
guys how I'm and why I'm doing that in a
certain way and starting off with the
station many modern-day ski lifts will
not have an entire building around their
station where you have to enter the
building as a skier and be in this room
full of all of this machinery typically
you actually stay outside as a skier and
they just put a small cover as a smaller
roof and enclose it over the technical
parts of the station so as you can see
here you don't really go inside a
building if you're running this but I am
building a very small building just
above the station to house all of the
technical parts so they don't get
damaged in the weather somehow and I'm
adding a few things in here as well
like these wheels I'm not really going
into detail so this is not a realistic
look inside the station at all I just
want to make it look somewhat believable
so I'm adding these tires which in real
life would be used to speed up the
chairs or the gondolas as they are
attached to the cable worth pointing out
also
I'm assuming that this will be a
detachable chairlifts there's a pretty
important stiff important difference to
be made between fixed grip chair lifts
which remain on the cable and thus
cannot slow down in the station and
detachable chair lifts which slow down
in the station are taken off the cable
there and a some kind of system that
keeps the moving in the station there
are different ways of doing that but
they'll typically have a long launch of
rubber tires in the station to speed it
up again and then once it reaches the
exact same speed as the cable there'll
be a hook which moves down onto the
cable clamps it and it's attached to the
cable and then it goes long again so
that's how they slow down those things
when they get into the station that was
a very basic explanation of something
that is much more complicated might be
interesting to look at but yeah that's
basically why I felt this station this
way why I've built this big cover above
the station to hide all of this
machinery and why stations are so long
in general anyway because it needs to
hide all of that stuff and it also needs
enough space to speed up the chairs and
the gondolas to the same speed as the
cable before it attaches them
unfortunately planet coaster is also
kind of missing the poets on this one to
be very honest because it actually just
speeds them up almost instantly once
they reach the end of the station
instead of a very gradual launch as you
all have in real life but I'm not too
concerned about that what I was really
concerned about though is the fact that
the station has supports on the sides
whereas most real life stations nowadays
will have thick supports in the middle
of the station and this kind of forced
me to try and come up with my own
station design and originally I wanted
to build the station exactly like you
would find a real-life topple Meyer
station specifically I wanted to build
the Uni G station design which is you
and I if you're interested in looking it
up I think it's a really nice one and
also it's very common you'll see it in a
lot of European ski resorts but yeah
with the supports on the side I didn't
really feel comfortable trying to build
that I thought it'd look a bit weird so
I'm going for something a bit more of my
own I guess trying to build something
else
although this is still based heavily on
dopa Meijer station namely of the D line
which is really the most recent line of
station designs of dopamine and
specifically I based it on I think a
gondola in Switzerland called Sano's law
which is a gondola with a square box the
station design which I thought was
really interesting so I took that for
this chair lifts I did do some of camera
adjustments to it later though so you'll
see a change bit and over here I'm
adding some details to the pillars this
is one of my other pet peeves as much as
I love the facts that frontier added
chair lifts and cable cars into the game
this is something that I've been waiting
for for a really long time and I've
actually been asking for it a few times
as well so I'm just super glad that it's
in the game now even though it has been
quite a while I know they've been in the
game for a long time it this is the
first time that I'm actually really
using them but yeah despite all that
they're missing some detail for one
they're missing the frames on top of the
pillars the parts where employees would
be able to hook themselves up as I
believe they should in case they're
they're working on maintenance or
something like that they're missing the
letters on the side of the supports
pillars the cat walks alongside the
wheels and also those nice orange bags
or whenever color they come in mostly
they are orange at the bottom of the
support pillars to protect skiers from
diving headfirst into a steel beam so
all of those details I was able to add
thanks to C BISM on the Steam Workshop
who has added all of these goodies to
add to your cable cars and chair lifts
in planet coasters so massive thanks go
out to him I probably wouldn't even have
started this series without him because
to me at least these elements are really
quintessential
to chair lifts and to building a
realistic looking ski resorts because
you'll find these things on almost all
ski lifts ever so yeah huge thanks to
him for them whatever they are but yeah
you're doing great work here and
without this the series probably
wouldn't exist so also it just looks
absolutely great so I want to say that
as well now at this point the lift
itself is pretty much finished with the
two stations in place and all the
pillars between them dressed up so yeah
it's time to basically shape out all of
the ski slopes and the way that I did
this is to try and make as much use of
the space that I have as possible while
at the same time also putting these
patches of forests between the slopes to
make it very clear where the slopes
begin and where they end
normally in real life you can much more
clearly see where the slopes are because
you'll typically have you know the
groomed snow where the slopes are and
then besides that you'll very clearly
see that ungroomed snow looks very
different so it very clearly defines
what is a slope and what isn't but here
it's not quite so easy to do so I'm
mostly just using the natural terrain 2d
markets the slopes and clearly it's just
the areas between the slope between the
trees where you can ski and I'm calling
them slopes now but I should probably
switch to the more European word for
piste
which I think will help get rid of some
confusion because I'll also try to use
slope to talk about the terraforming
aspects of it so yeah I'm just gonna
call these pieces if you don't mind you
can also call them trails or runs or
whatever other names they have for them
but I'll just be referring to them as
beasts from now on and also another
thing to help the market where the
priests are is that actually the right
way to pronounce it um they're just
gonna have to get right here but yeah
the way to know how they are is also
just checking the snow lenses I believe
they're called which will be able to
artificially create snow in case there
hasn't been enough snowfall which given
that this is a ski resort on rather
small Hills so probably not at a very
high altitude
I'm realistically gonna need these
things because global warming is a thing
and ski resorts are getting less and
less snow on average every year
and yeah these things are becoming more
and more necessary so in case there's
not enough snowfall but the temperatures
are low enough to snow then the snow
Lance's will be able to draw water from
some kind of artificial lake and create
snow with it and basically keep the
piece up and running
so yeah that's quite an important detail
and also just something that very
clearly makes an area look like an
actual piece I'm also adding some small
poles to demarcate what kind of slopes
you we have or gone I'm really gonna
keep confusing these works hard and I
what what kind of piece do we have a
kind of runs we have whatever and I'm
following the European system here so
I'll be going for blue beginner slopes
medium slopes will be red and the
advanced or expert slopes will be black
and I'm not entirely sure about exactly
what kind of difficulty they should have
this is always something which is I
think also to some extent up to the left
to the imagination of whatever ski
resort is managing you know the the
different piste
but generally speaking I think a black
slope will be about a 30% slope or more
or actually will be about 30 degrees
slope or more which is 66 percent
because 100 percent slope would be 45
degrees yeah things get really good
thing here so anyway over 30 degrees
would be a blank slope and then I'd say
between 20 30 degrees should be a red
slope and then below that will be a blue
slope or piste
Oh ever and you know generally speaking
it's hard to exactly demarcate that's
because it's always a question of
whether you're looking at the steepest
section of a certain length of piste or
if you're looking at the average
steepness of a piece so it's always
difficult to kind of figure that out but
I'm just gonna try and do what makes
sense here and I'll explain a bit more
about exactly why I chose a
certain difficulty for a certain piece
adds the end of this whole series I
think but it's something that I'm trying
to keep in mind because I do want to
include some areas of the ski resort
which are 30 degrees or beyond and some
areas which are very flat and wide also
so that beginners will be able to ski so
as much as I can I'm also gonna try and
keep in mind the logic of a skier you
know what do you need what do people
like what kind of variety should there
be to try and also make this as much as
I can a resort that would be very fun to
ski or at least something where I could
imagine myself skiing as well I'm not
the best skier but I've basically done
it almost every year of my life so at
least I have experience on pretty much
every kind of slope
so I think that should help me to some
extent try and make this as well because
if anything I do want to try and
restrict my videos to things that I am
at least some kind of authority on so
yeah that's also why I've always wanted
to make a video about ski resorts just
because it's something that has been
interesting me for a really long time
it's a passion of mine and god I still
haven't made a video of this at least in
planet coaster if you actually go back
to rollercoaster tycoon 3 one of my
favorite things I've made in that game
was actually a custom scenery set to
make double Meier gondolas and share
lifts by using a CT in the game and it
was quite complicated and I remember it
being absolutely annoying and terrible
to make but it was really fun trying to
figure out how these things look exactly
and how to remodel them in step and get
them in the game and get them to work
somehow if you're interested in seeing
parts of that's I do have a video on my
channel of clumsy tiger which is an old
inverted coaster that I made in roller
coaster tycoon 3 which has a cable car
video as well and I'll link that down in
the description as well just in case
you're interested now finally I did copy
the station of
the the welder what would you call it
the valley station over unto the the
peak of the chairlifts here but I did
want to add something else to it so
here's the cabin where the operator is
going to sit and operate the ride that's
just part of realism something that I
didn't want to miss but I'm definitely
not going to dress these things up like
it's some kind of themed parts of the
theme park or whatever I'm really going
to keep this very strictly technical and
as simple as possible especially with a
lot of these modern the chair lifts
you'll just see that they're basically
limited to the bare minimum in terms of
architecture needed to keep these things
running see how this is all quite simple
although I do have to say I kind of do
like the look of this station I had to
take some time to get used to it and you
might also notice that I messed with it
a little bit the glass is less tall now
and the station as a whole is much more
flat looking but I think it's a decent
look although that said in the next
episode I do want to work on some very
different station designs anyway moving
on from there I'm placing a lot of trees
in this area to basically mark outs that
little path which is going to be a blue
slope which i think is quite important
because the the general slopes of this
hill are quite steep so there's really
not there's really no way to make a
natural blue slope here but what you're
very often find at ski resorts is that
they'll use roads leaning up the
mountains as slopes or pastes Oh God
in in winter months to try and have some
kind of beginner feasts in case that the
mountain is very rough and in case the
terrain doesn't really allow for easier
slopes so that's something that I wanted
to have go up the hill as well not to
mention that it very well connects the
three different pieces that we could
have going down the mountain as well so
I think that's a nice touch also and
to be very honest I think ski resorts
also kind of use these things to cheat
on the number of slopes they have or the
length of slopes they have not really
cheats but it's kind of like Lick Bates
you know very often ski resorts will
advertise that they have 70 kilometres
of piste or 50 kilometres of piste and
you know it's not really representative
of whether these are wide groomed slopes
or whether these are just little paths
running through the forests on and on I
remember a ski resort in Japan that I've
been to where you could go down the
entire mountain on this one little slope
that was basically just a road leading
to the top of the mountain you couldn't
even get off of it and go to like
regular piste slopes oh my god it's you
just had to stay on this little path I
believe that was somewhere on Bondi
Mountain I don't think it was the entire
length of the mountain but it was
definitely the longest little path
through the forests that I've ever taken
on skis although at the same time I also
really liked these things you know
there's something to having a variety of
different piste other resorts I really
like very wide and straight pieces but
also these little paths through the
forest
especially on your first go through them
are just a really nice kind of
adventurous explorative little you know
look into nature and the general area
which is really nice I mean at the end
of the day for me especially as a Dutch
person it's really cool to go skiing
because you're in the mountains you're
in a region where there are actually
elevation differences and that alone
just makes exploring it and looking
around you so much cooler although I'm
pretty sure that for pretty much
everybody the views and the overall
nature is just a really big thrall to
skiing as well now here I'm working on
some of the other mountains which I
won't work on yet in this video but I
just wanted to shape them out to get an
idea of what I wanted these things to be
shaped like but as you can see it's
difficult to make these hills with very
small brushes that we have in planet
coaster at least it's manageable though
and with a lot of smoothing you can get
some decent sand and smooth hills as
well so that's not too bad but yeah I'm
gonna probably build a big gondola to
the top of this hill right here and then
some kind of smaller ski lifts to the
other one whatever happens we'll see in
the next episode so yeah thanks for
watching guys and see you guys next time
[Music]
you
[Music]